[Música]
mar y su familia comparten el dolor con
las otras familias que vinieron a
homenajear la memoria de sahar y de sus
ocho compañeros que murieron en la
explosión del puerto de beirut tenía 27
años ya había conseguido ser una de las
pocas mujeres paramédico en esta unidad
de bomberos la primera y única que
acudió al puerto de encajar habría ido
de todas maneras al puerto le apasionaba
su trabajo y no reparaba en el peligro
pero sin sus superiores hubieran estado
al tanto del nitrato de amonio no lo
habrían dejado ir directamente a la
muerte fue una negligencia de los
políticos como mariah mariana perdió a
su hermana la explosión ahora capitanea
la lucha de las familias de las víctimas
del puerto y su dolor le animó a
adjuntar al resto de las familias y
formar una asociación para reclamar el
derecho a una indemnización ya que se
haga una investigación justa
hemos luchado mucho para conseguir un
subsidio familiar para que las familias
de las víctimas puedan recibir la misma
asignación mensual que las familias de
militares fallecidos y ahora estamos
presionando para que los hijos
se han quedado huérfanos de padres
reciban una cuota escolar si pudiera
daría mi vida por la tuya saad eres mi
alma nunca te olvidaré y encontraré la
verdad para ti para mantener la memoria
viva los familiares de las víctimas se
han estado reuniendo cada día 4 de mes
para reclamar justicia y para que la
lucha que han iniciado no sea en vano
sólo siento rabia no es suficiente con
que nos paguen una compensación
económica el dinero no nos va a devolver
a nuestros seres queridos queremos saber
qué pasó queremos que los responsables
rindan cuentas
se cumple un año de la tragedia y
todavía no hay respuestas el coraje de
mujeres como amar y animaría animan a
muchos libaneses a unirse a seguir
reclamando justicia en un momento en el
que líbano afronta su peor crisis
económica política y social de los
últimos tiempos
[Aplausos]